على الرغم من كل الجبن الضعيف لبايدن
وعدم كفاءته ، لا
يزال هناك طريق أمامه لإنهاء هذه المأساة
في أوكرانيا دون وقوع الأمريكيين
في شرك حرب شنيعة ودموية للغاية
[موسيقى]
تحت جو بايدن أمريكا لا
يخشى ولا يحترم هناك لم
يكن هناك وقت  حيث
تم التعامل مع بلدنا بالطريقة التي هي عليها الآن ،
تقوم البلدان الأخرى بإلقاء المحاضرات
وإخبارنا بما يجب القيام
به وهذا هو السبب في أننا نشهد
الفوضى والفوضى وسفك الدماء في جميع أنحاء العالم
[موسيقى
] ، يجب أن نوضح
أنه  أمام خيارين للتفاوض على
السلام في الوقت الحالي أو مواجهة
عواقب وخيمة بما في ذلك
الدفع للتخلص نهائيًا من الاعتماد
على الطاقة الروسية ونحن نتحدث
عن ذلك إلى الأبد أو لفترة طويلة
لأنه بدون الأموال التي تأتي من
الطاقة روسيا لا تعمل
ولكن  لجعل هذا التهديد موثوقًا به ،
يتعين على الولايات المتحدة إنهاء
حرب بايدن السخيفة على الطاقة الأمريكية على الفور ،
فقد كنا مستقلين في مجال الطاقة
[موسيقى]
نحتاج إلى المساعدة في
ع هذا الغزو الوحشي علينا أيضًا
أن نطهر من تعفن مؤسستنا للسياسة الخارجية الفاشلة ، فقد
تعفن بالفعل حتى النخاع قبل أن
يقودنا هؤلاء المجانين إلى
طريق الخراب الوطني والحرب العالمية الثالثة
[الموسيقى]
كل يوم هناك المزيد
دليل على أن انتخابات 2020
، وبالمناسبة هي أبعد من وجهة
نظر الأدلة ، هناك الكثير من الحقيقة على
أنها كانت فاسدة وكانت مزورة
ومليئة بالمخالفات ،
وبعبارة أخرى تم تزويرها
[تصفيق]
لذا ركضت مرتين
وفزت مرتين  حققنا أداءً أفضل في المرة الثانية
مما فعلنا في المرة الأولى التي حصلنا فيها
على 12 مليون صوت إضافي والآن
قد نضطر إلى الترشح مرة أخرى